why is the corporate press and Trump
going after DeSantis well it's obvious
it's obvious that he is the real threat
uh here's a little video of uh to say
this and Elon because I think this is a
nice way to cap the show on what this
perhaps is all about
um we're absolutely committed to freedom
of speech on Level Playing Field and
just a vigorous debate and hopefully uh
this can be a platform that brings
people of Divergent political views to
exchange those views and and have some
Minds will be changed one way or the
other and um but it's just incredibly
important as you as you highlight that
the the first amendment is irrelevant if
all the media and all the and the
government are operating at lockstep
it's uh it makes you know the most
important Amendment the one that was
most urgently added to the Constitution
um moot if you if you can't have uh free
and open debate so
so Twitter was indeed expensive uh but
free speech is priceless
great line right just absolutely great
life so you have to decide for yourself
is Joy read right when she calls them
fascists and authoritarians or when you
listen to the guys themselves how
thoughtful and decent Elon comes across
as he's defending free speech and bought
a company that is purging money left and
right and has a Litany of problems that
he's publicly talking about he bought it
for 44 billion dollars because he
believes in a plurality of voices and
free speech and everything else and then
somehow that same guy sees something in
Ron DeSantis that he wants to amplify
and you have to figure out for yourself
do you think that is good or do you
think that's fascist and authoritarian
[Music]
thank you